- Triple-decker hamburger
made out of a doughnut.
I'm going to make Steve eat one of those.
Steve's going to eat a
triple-decker hamburger
out of a doughnut.
(upbeat music)
- All right, where are we going, Colin?
- We're going to the
Los Angeles County Fair.
- Are you going to win me a prize?
Excited?
- [Colin] I'm excited.
- [Freddie] Whoo!
- [Steven] Oh my God!
- I already see, like,
nine things I want to eat.
- Doughnuts, cookie dough, now you know.
- We're going to play a
little game of telephone.
We're going to go to one booth,
- Eat that amazing food,
ask them what their favorite booth is,
go to that booth,
- And then we're going to go
on, and on, and on, and on,
- And by the end of this,
I plan to have what everybody
has at the end of a fair,
a sunburn and a stomach ache.
- Let's go!
- Our fair chaperon suggested
we start at Chicken Charlie's,
which sounds fine to me,
I always can eat chicken.
And look at that booth!
Woah!
I think we have to get a
Totally Fried Guacamole,
the triple-decker burger,
and I think we need some fried Oreos, too.
- [Steven] Are we going to eat all that?
- [Colin] Yeah!
- We're at booth number one guys.
- Fried guac
- Oh my god!
- Fried guacamole is awesome.
- It's literally just guacamole
with a layer of dough around it.
- It's kinda healthy, right?
- The crispness of the fried batter
is really, really on point.
- This is maybe the grossest
concoction I've ever seen,
and I love it.
- Triple-decker burger
with Steven's favorite,
Krispy Kreme doughnuts.
- Glazed, I don't need you
anymore Freddie, I've got this.
- It's sweet, it's savory, it
tastes like a heart attack.
- The meat and the doughnut
are the same texture.
I will say this is a
balanced meal, though.
Like we have the meat,
we have the veggies,
and now dessert.
- I'm not mad at it.
- Wow.
- I love it.
- I was expecting, like,
to crunch into the Oreo,
but look at that, they
somehow made the Oreo
into a soft, gushy, pleasant surprise.
- If you were a 10 year old,
which would be your favorite?
- [Steve] Fried Oreos.
- [Freddie] Fried Oreos.
- If I was 10, I still
think Fried Guacamole
would be my favorite.
- You were one of those kids.
- 10 on the 10-year-old scale for sure.
- Totally.
- Heart attack variable, 10.
- Yeah, I'm going to have
one in, like, 20 minutes.
- 11.
- Creativity?
- I give them an eight.
- Total score 28 out of 30.
Almost perfect, but we can get better.
- If you weren't going
to eat at your booth,
what other booth at the fair,
do you think would be where
you would get your food?
- I keep hearing a lot
about fried watermelon.
I do not know exactly
the name of the place.
- A fair legend, I like it,
okay, fried watermelon it is.
(upbeat fair music)
- [Steven] You alright there?
- Yeah, just covering up.
It's like the Sahara out here.
- We're on the hunt for the
booth with the fried watermelon.
We don't know the name of the booth,
we're just rolling with the punches,
seeing what we stumble upon.
- Do you guys have fried watermelon?
- Argh!
We're going to have three
sticks of fried watermelon?
Should we get pineapple, too, guys?
- [Colln] Let's do two
watermelons, one pineapple.
- [Woman] The best upside-down pineapple.
- That is crazy!
- [Woman] Here is the
queen of the deep fried,
it's the deep-fried watermelon.
- [Freddie] I don't even have words.
- Fried watermelon?
It's like, you'd think
it would melt, right?
- No, still super fresh, still--
- They picked this
watermelon out yesterday.
This is fried pizza.
- Cheers guys.
- [Steven] That's how you make pizza.
- [Colin] Uh huh.
- [Steven] Why is this not done more?
- That's weird, I like it.
- [Freddie] Super flaky.
- It has the taste of a pizza,
and the texture of a glazed doughnut.
- If I was 10, I would love this.
- Heart attack,
this is not going to
send you to the hospital.
- Six
- Creativity, I give it an eight.
- Yeah, I mean, it's pizza, fried.
10 plus six, plus eight, is 24.
We gotta ask them where we're going next.
- If you're not eating
at your own lovely booth,
where else in the LA County
Fair do you like to eat?
- Well, let's see, we'll eat at Pepe's,
which is over on Palm.
- [Steven] You ready?
- Pepe's it is, let's go!
- [Steven] Go.
You guys are standing there, let's go.
- Hi, I'm Lola. The number
one item that I sell,
I started with the fish
tacos, the grilled fish tacos.
It's healthy, guilt-free.
- This straw is for Steve,
I don't want his cooties.
- [Steven] You guys ready?
This is like Taco Truck all over again.
- Day one guys, it's a throwback.
This taco is for you, Andrew.
(inspirational music)
- Cheers, Colin you always jump the gun.
- I always forget the cheers.
- Yes!
- The best part, not fried.
- [Steven] If I worked at the fair,
I'd probably eat here a lot.
You just get so tired
of all the fried food.
- You don't get tired of fried food,
you just have to stop
eating it or you'll die.
- This place gave me a
whole new pep in my step.
I was starting to feel a
little weak at one point.
- Yeah this is a good,
like, palate cleanser.
I think our rubric should be scratched.
This is our intermission.
- Because on the heart
attack scale, it gets a one.
- And you don't need a heart
attack to have a good time.
- We were told that the best
funnel cake at the fair,
is at the Mad Hatter.
- Funnel cake, scary animal, let's go.
- We're gonna get one Holy
Moly Double-decker Funnel Cake.
We got chocolate-dipped bacon,
and a double-decker funnel
cake with strawberries.
- [Freddie] This is my cutie for the day.
- What is going on?
- Cheers, guys.
- What do you know
about chocolate, Steven?
- I know absolutely nothing.
- I'm not a fan.
- Me neither. (laughs)
- It just tastes like
chocolate-covered paper.
- Ew.
- It's not bad.
- Funnel cake, it's why
they invented the fair.
We're going to give you a heart attack.
- This isn't your normal funnel cake.
- Nope.
- It's so light.
- It's not actually a heart attack.
- It's not crazy sweet.
- It's starting to look
like a heart attack though.
That's for sure.
- 10-year-old factor, this is a 10.
- This is a 20.
- 10.
- You find me a 10 year old
who doesn't like funnel cake,
I'll show you a very, very sad kid.
- Creativity?
- It's sort of light and feathery.
- It's different.
- And it's also a double decker.
Which adds a new element.
- For me, nine.
It's a visual heart attack,
wasn't exactly a heart attack though.
Fried guacamole, that was a heart attack.
This is, yeah, like a seven.
26.
- Yeah.
- Really good.
- Solid score, funnel cake.
We made it.
- We made it.
- LA County Fair.
- We learned that the fair
is a great place to go once a year.
You go more than once a year,
you'll be on your back.
- I'm going to explode
right now, actually.
- Should we get some more,
uh, fried guac on the way out?
- Yes!
Peace.
(jazzy upbeat music)
- You do not want me behind
the wheel of a car right now.